guys April is around the corner and you
know what's gonna come out in April not
infinite well it is Westworld season two
it's finally returning I'm excited to
see this trailer where I'm sure it's
gonna have a lot of intrigue I ain't
really gonna know anything of how it's
gonna go down well let's kind of look at
East world or Shogun world Wiest world
yeast we're all bread products carbs
lost carbs the others Wow
[Music]
dreams don't mean anything don't every
building hemsworth an answer doesn't
seem to satisfy you dreams into
everything because they come all
literally honest listen our great to be
made your robots here another talking
about a little bit late the price you'd
have to pay if there was a reckoning who
is that
[Music]
shift the words our head Scouts can tell
[Music]
he's still getting he still gets to walk
around
oh she go crazy
[Music]
there's beauty among you are
nice right you're still around
everything ten miles and all these
things blood
nice there we go
[Music]
we saw blips - Tessa Thompson
they wanted to place hidden from God we
had something else in mind and dark
won't see that oh there it is
Shogun world or whatever it's kind of
let a whole charge against killing a
bunch of yeah you killed Anthony no big
deal one shot here where look like Evan
Rachel Wood made it out of West world
yeah it looks like she's in the real
world at some point and Tandy Newton
goes to the Shogun place oh she's gonna
be teaming up with them and she's kind
of they're kind of building her up to be
some type of like Rogue Warrior
liberators yeah that makes sense because
Tubman of the machine
knowing Shogun yeah that's why she would
be there well maybe she finds out that
there's another Park and is like well
the same thing has gotta be happening
over there I gotta go help these people
now too
that's what they should do for every
season is everything every part of when
also I saw Jimmy Simpson in here which
makes me wonder if that's only a
flashback or if they're gonna keep doing
their dual timelines thing look like it
was one of those like hallucinatory
she's when they're when their memories
start to mess with each other and they
see projections of their memories nor
dreams yeah yeah something like that I
love this show or Game of Thrones
sets you up for like so many characters
you love the way they're teasing things
I'm sure is not gonna go down how the
trailers making it look like they kind
of teased at Harris's character why is
he just kind of wandering around still
that's what he wanted all along was like
the true danger and the true you know
reality of the hey I just let him I
don't know see that's the thing I'm very
curious about how that's gonna be
explained or whatever or if some of them
hate him and some of them don't or or or
what you know because I'm sure that he's
thrilled with the way West world is
James because that's kind of the arc of
that first season is well the the lines
ever given him
made it seem like he was against what's
going on right now though interest they
were kind of building him up to be like
some type of human hero for us my
favorite shot was when the AI within the
skin tissue wasn't complete and then it
was already like taking down people yeah
it's gonna be freaky that's gonna be
really creepy that's gonna be early too
I bet it's gonna be like early on in the
season maybe a montage as West world
crime they're probably gonna tease but
now we're gonna get a lot more
exploration it's gonna be beyond west
world the first season you kind of know
or at least I felt like you could expect
a certain amount of things to happen you
could expect it yeah all these machines
are gonna wake up and we're gonna
overthrow a-list world West world West
world and now I don't know exactly where
this season wants to head and that's
exciting to me is all that mystery you
said whist world we swilled wish we'll
watch how to dad we swear and you get a
glimpses of some new characters too it's
not just returning characters like this
one chick who I noticed in the trailer
at 53 seconds felt like maybe she had
been scalped and then she put it back on
you'd think with all the success Tessa
Thompson has been having lately they
might try to throw her in the trailer a
little more she wasn't that main of a
character in the first season so also
makes sense why you don't really see her
in it yeah maybe she'll either be either
a surprise in the way the user this
season or it'll be another one of those
like in the montage recapping what
happened after in Hopkins well yeah I
mean what I like about this is instead
of trying to manipulate us into thinking
this is all-out war it's like you get
the sense of borås brewing and building
up and there's probably gonna be some
violent ass sequences between AI versus
human they're not trying to manipulate
the audience and they're thinking that's
what it's gonna be that's gonna be like
a some giant actions you know season
yeah every episode is gonna be a bunch
of so gonna be some questions to answer
and some mystery to build up to this is
creepy this is my this is my nightmare
that I can't wait to experience yeah
well thanks for telling us this was out
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get notified every
time one of our bids is up you can check
us on patreon become a patreon check
today why because I oughta
well movies that from God say what movie
that's where I'm putting the couch
you know a movie that's right liar liar
Jim here